things that are happening criminal
justice reform as you know we just heard
word got word that Mitch McConnell and
the group we're gonna be putting it up
for a vote
we have great Democrat support great
Republican support so criminal justice
reform something that people have been
trying to get how long has he many years
many many years looks like it's going to
be passing hopefully famous last words
on a very bipartisan way and it's it's
really something we're all very proud of
and again tremendous support from
Republicans and tremendous support from
Democrats and I think it's going to get
a very good vote and we'll see soon
enough but it will be up for a vote very
shortly a lot of years have been waiting
for it the other thing the farm bill is
moving along nicely and I guess they'll
be voting on Friday or so but pretty
soon and we think the farm bill is in
very good shape a lot of good things are
happening with it and our farmers are
well taken care of and again that'll be
quite bipartisan and it'll happen pretty
soon and then we have these you won the
wall that'll be the one that will be the
easiest of all what do you think Chuck
maybe not it's called funding the
government so we're gonna see but I will
tell you the wall will get but belt
we'll see what happens
it is not an easy situation because the
Democrats have a different view I think
and I can say the Republicans we have
great Republican support
we don't have Democrats support but
we're going to talk about that now we're
going to see one thing that I do have to
say is tremendous amounts of wall have
already been built and a lot of a lot of
wall when you include the renovation of
existing fences and walls renovated a
tremendous amount and we've done a lot
of work in San Diego we're building new
walls right now and we've right next to
San Diego we've completed a major
section of wall and it's really worked
well so a lot of wall has been built we
don't talk about that but we might as
well start because it's building it's
being built right now big sections of
wall and we will continue that and
one way or the other it's going to get
built I'd like not to see a government
closing the shutdown we will see what
happens over the next short period of
time but the wall is a very important
thing to us I might put it a different
way border security is extremely
important and we have to take care of
border security when you look at what
happened with the caravans with the
people with a lot of we shut it down we
had no choice we shut it down but it
could be a lot easier if we had real
border security I just want to pay my
respects to the Border Patrol agents and
officers they've been incredible the ice
agents and officers they've been
incredible and very importantly our
military our military went in and they
did an incredible job they have been
really really spectacular a lot of the
people that wanted to come in to the
country and really they willing to come
in no matter how they wanted to come in
they were going to come in even a rough
way many of these people are leaving now
and they're going back to their
countries Honduras Guatemala El Salvador
in other countries they're leaving if
you notice it's getting a lot less
crowded in Mexico and a lot of them are
going to stay in Mexico and the Mexican
government's been working with us very
well so we appreciate that but they
haven't been coming into our country we
can't let people come in that way so
that's pretty much it we're going to
talk about the wall I wanted to talk
about criminal justice reform just to
let you know how positive that is I want
to talk about the farm bill how positive
that is and I want to talk about the
wall and I will tell you it's a tough
issue because we are in very opposite
sides of I think I can say border
security but certainly the wall but the
wall would get built a lot of the wall
is built it's been very effective
I asked for a couple of notes on that if
you look at San Diego illegal traffic
dropped 92 percent once the wall was up
El Paso illegal traffic dropped 72
percent then ultimately 95 percent once
the wall was up in Tucson Arizona
illegal traffic drop 92 percent Yuma
it dropped illegal traffic
85 to 96% I mean and that when when I
say dropped the only reason we even have
any percentage where people got through
is because they walk and go around areas
that aren't built it dropped virtually a
hundred percent in the areas where the
wall is so I mean it's very effective if
you really want to find out how
effective a wall is just ask Israel
99.9% effective and our wall will be
every bit as good as that if not better
so we've done a lot of work on the wall
a lot of wall is built a lot of people
don't know that a lot of wall is
renovated we have walls that were very
bad condition that are now in a one
tip-top shape and frankly some wall has
been reinforced by our military our
military's done a fantastic job so the
wall will get built but we may not we
may not have an agreement today we
probably won't but we'd have an
agreement on other things that are
really good Nancy would you like to say
something to meet with you so that we
can work together in a bipartisan way to
meet the needs of the American people I
think the American people recognize that
we must keep government open that a
shutdown is not worth anything and that
you should not have a shutdown you have
the House of Representatives because in
the Senate we need 60 yeah but I can't
excuse me but I can't get it passed in
the house but it's not gonna pass in the
Senate I don't wanna waste but the fact
is you can get it started that way the
house we could get passed very easy okay
and we do but the problem is the Senate
because we need 10 Democrats to vote and
the point is is that their equities to
be weighed and we're here to have a
conversation in a full way so I don't
think we should have a debate in front
of the press on this but the fact is the
Senate the House Republicans could bring
up this bill if they had the votes
immediately
set the tone for what you want if we
thought we were going to get it passed
in the Senate Nancy we would do it
immediately we get it passed very easily
in the house we would get into this
Nancy I'd have it passed in two seconds
it doesn't matter though because we
can't get it passed in the Senate
because we need ten Democrat votes let
us have our conversation that works for
me with the press again but the fact is
is that legislating and which is what we
do you begin you make your point you
state your case that's what the House
Republicans would do if they had the
votes but there are no votes in the
house a majority of votes for a role no
matter what if I needed the votes for
the wall in the house I would have them
in one session would be done it doesn't
help because we need ten Democrats and
okay let me ask you this just and we're
doing this in a very friendly manner
it doesn't help for me to take a vote in
the house where I will win easily with
the Republicans it doesn't help to take
that vote because I'm not going to get
the vote of the Senate I need ten
senators have the white house the white
house is done and the house would give
me the vote if I wanted it but I can't
because I need Nancy I need ten votes
from chuck let me say something
Nancy I do and we need border secured
Nancy Nancy
we need border security is very simple
we need border security people are
pouring into our country including
terrorists we have terrorists we caught
ten terrorists over the last very short
period of time ten these are very
serious people our border agents all of
our law enforcement has been incredible
what they've done but we caught ten
terrorists these are people that were
looking to do harm
we need the wall we need more important
than anything we need border security of
which the wall is just a piece but it's
important Chuck did you want to say
here's what I want to say we have a lot
of disagreements here the Washington
Post today gave you a whole lot of
Pinocchio's because they say you
constantly miss state how much the wall
is bill how much of the wall is built
and how much is there but that's not the
point here we have a disagreement about
the washing of whether it's effective or
they're not on border security but on
the wall
we do not want to shut down the
government you were called 20 times to
shut down the government you say I want
to shut down the government we don't we
want to come to an agreement if we can't
come to an agreement we have solutions
that will pass the House and Senate
right now and will not shut down the
government and that's what we're urging
you to do not threaten to shut down the
government because you can't let me say
something mr. president you just say my
way or we'll shut down the government we
have a proposal that Democrats and
Republicans will support to do a CR that
will not shut down the government we
urge you to take and if it's not good
border security is very good and if it's
not good border security
I won't take its what there is when you
look at these numbers of the
effectiveness of our border security and
when you look at the job that we're
doing which is effective can I be can I
tell you something yeah you just send it
out a wall these are only areas where
you have the wall want to do you have
walls Chuck it's effective we you don't
have Voyles it is not effective yeah
we've come in here as the first branch
of government yeah article 1 the
legislative branch we're coming in in
good faith to negotiate with you about
how we can keep the government open
we're gonna keep it open if we have
border secure if we don't have border
security we're not going to keep it and
it's the same border you're bragging
about what has been done by only want to
do the same thing we did last year this
year that's our proposal if it's good
then it's good now and it won't shut
down the gun shop we can build up a much
bigger section let's debate in private
ok yeah let's debate in private we need
water security I think we all agree that
we need water yes no good we do see we
get along thank you everybody
your security you need you need the wall
the wall is a part of border security
we need border security the wall is a
part of border security you can't have
very good border security without the
wall now on our response the experts say
you can do border security without a
wall which is wasteful and doesn't solve
the problem
it totally solves the problem and it's
very important we who have needs
the economy has its people are losing
their jobs the markets in our move our
members are already well we have the
lowest unemployment that we've had in 50
years their office is now because of the
transition there people are not ashamed
in the Senate Nancy we've gained in the
Senate excuse me did we win the Senate
when the president brags that he won
North Dakota and Indiana he's in real
trouble
well I did we did win dr. Carter we came
in here in good faith and and we're
entering into a of this kind of a
discussion in the public but it's not
fair there's you know a new cold
transparency I know it's not
transparency when we're not stipulating
to a set of facts and when we want to
have a debate with you about saying we
confront some lies that's it you know
what we need border security that's what
we're gonna be talking about border
security if we don't have border
security will shut down the government
this country needs border security
the wall is a part of border security
let's have a talk we're gonna get the
wall built and we've done a lot of wall
over Eddie it's a big section it's a big
part of it it's a big part of it we need
to have effective border security we
need a wall in certain parts no not in
all parts but in certain parts of a
2,000 mile border we need a wall we are
doing it much under budget we're
actually way under budget or the areas
that we've renovated in areas that we've
built I would say if we got if we got
five billion dollars we could do a
tremendous chunk of wall we're gonna say
look we have to get the one this isn't a
question this is a national emergency
drugs are pouring into our country
people with tremendous medical
difficulty and medical problems are
pouring in and admitted in many cases
that it's contagious they're pouring
into our country we have to have border
security we have to have a wall as part
of border security and I don't think we
really disagree so much I also know that
you know Nancy's in a situation where
it's not easy for her to talk right now
and I understand that and I fully
understand that we're gonna have a good
discussion and we're gonna see what
happens ya know we have to have border
security
please don't characterize the strength
that I bring to this need as a leader of
the House Democrats who just want a big
different elections have consequences
the president says that's right and
that's why the country is doing so well
the president is representing his cards
over there are not facts we have to have
an evidence base conversation about what
does work what money has been spent and
how effective it is this isn't that this
is about the security of our country we
take an oath to plan
and defense we don't want to have that
mr. territory by anyone I agree with so
let us have a conversation where we
don't have to contradict in public
statistics that you put forth but
instead can have a conversation about
what will really work but what the
American people deserve from us at this
uncertain time in their lives one thing
I think we can agree on is we shouldn't
shut down the government over a dispute
and you want to shut it down about the
last time Chuck you shut it down oh no
and then you up wedding sorry quickly
and when he I don't want to do what you
did 20 times y'all have called for I
will shut down the government if I don't
get my wool none of us have you ever
know so you said you want to put that
who said it I'll take it ok good you
know what I'll say yes if we don't get
what we want one way or the other
whether it's through you through a
military through anything you want to
call I will shut down the gun okay up
there enough and is around and I
disagree I am proud to shut down the
government for border security Chuck
because the people of this country don't
want criminals and people that have lots
of problems and drugs pouring into our
country so I will take the mantle I will
be the one to shut it down I'm not gonna
blame you for it the last time you shut
it down it didn't work I will take the
medal of shutting down and I'm gonna
shut it down for border but we believe
you shouldn't share it down thank you
very much everybody
a lot of friends of mine want it a lot
of people that Chuck and Nancy know very
well one and I think people you'd like
we have a lot of people that want the
job chief of staff so we'll be seeing
what happens very soon we're no rush why
we're no rush why because we have a
wonderful chief of staff right now we
just know we are in no rush over a
period of a week or two or maybe less
we'll announce who it's going to be but
we have a lot of people that want the
position thank you very much